[Musique]
super content d'être là quand j'ai lu le
scénario j'ai vu qu'ils avaient pris mon
nom pour le titre du film j'étais
forcément taillé pour le rôle voilà en
quoi consistaient mon audition
[Musique]
un tournage c'est super lent surtout
quand tu compare à ma vie de tous les
jours du coup pour mettre du rythme à
chaque prise je disais tout mes
répliques du film à fond les ballons
comme ça le réalisateur avait le choix
au montage
bosser avec jim carrey c'était
incroyable je cite et ses répliques
toute la journée splendide
vous vous rappelez au millénaire de la
porte désolé mais j'accélère est en
cours non mais j'ai des amis je pèse 28
kg tout habillé mais ça ne fait pas de
demander non non oui peut être bien une
fois mais j'ai pour habitude de jamais
en parler
pour g speed salut
m
pendant que je heurter violemment les
eaux sombres et froides du pacifique
je me suis rendu compte de ma situation
alors à je ne sais absolument pas où je
vais et l'eau de mer ça pique les yeux
c'est à cet instant précis je ne devrait
plus être sur cette planète mais il se
trouve que j'y suis encore pourquoi
parce que monsieur a tiré sur moi je
suis au courant a tiré sur moi
oui j'ai entendu ce pas la peine d'en
parler pendant des heures j'ai compris
ça va je suis tout mouillé je suis
complètement gelé j'ai un poisson
puisque sur la tête c'est clairement je
n'arriverai jamais à rejoindre san
francisco tout seul d'accord aller en
voiture sérieux que tu veux vraiment
m'aider je crois que c'est un petit peu
de ma faute si tu te retrouve bloquée si
non c'est pas un petit peu de ta faute
c'est juste carrément de ta faute
ok c'est carrément de ma faute est ce
qu'on peut y aller oui une virée entre
potes songe à le regretter
soli le fille au cinéma le 12 février
voici lille d'où je viens une île
paradisiaque
plage de sable plein cascades
vertigineuses montagnes russes à volonté
j'ai jamais eu besoin de prendre le bus
pour aller à l'école parce que je
faisais le tour de ville en moins de
deux secondes toute façon il n'y avait
pas d'école jeu c'est une île de rêve il
vous dit
[Musique]